it's a millionare theme our we're
talking with real millionaires so we can
show you how to be millionaires in the
process of doing that we're defeating a
lot of the mythology around the wealthy
number one piece of mythology you
inherit the money is how you become
wealthy 88% that's almost nine out of
ten millionaires and there's nine point
four million of them started with
nothing they didn't did not inherit
money in order to become a millionaire
mythology number two you would be a
athlete and actor or a rock star in
order to be a millionaire no less than
1% of millionaires fall in those
categories all added together the number
one category of millionaires are small
business owners 32% the number two
category of millionaires is
professionals and that's white-collar
executive types including but not
limited to engineers doctors lawyers
architects those kinds of folks but it
also includes a CEO of a major company
or a CFO of a major company those kinds
of things so working a job of that type
or owning your own business and so I've
had one of each this our mythology
number three you have to be brilliant to
be a millionaire nope
Tom Stanley's book you need to be smart
but you and wise but you don't need to
be brilliant
Tom Stanley's book the millionaire mind
he came up with 38 correlating
statistical items that indicate
millionaire status or multi millionaire
status and then he ranked them in order
of most often shown statistically to
least often shown out of the 38 the
least of all 38 that he measured as an
indicator was GPA your GPA is almost
never an indicator now you do need to
get up in the threes high twos and a
minimum and you can't be running around
with FS and DS and do this stuff okay
because that's an indication you're just
not bright or you're not disciplined
but but this idea that somehow you have
to have 4.2 you have to be a genius
child in order to be a millionaire is
ridiculous
oh and millionaire myth number three
number four number four all wealthy
people are evil and they got all their
money by cheating
now same list of character qualities
when listed as that indicate the ability
to build wealth and keep wealth number
one character quality extreme fanatical
integrity being honest with all people
most millionaires got there by being
more honest than the average cat not
less honest that's statistical data
that's not your brother-in-law spouting
liberal pablum that's real data so you
got it really I mean you have to stop
and realize that there's an agenda with
this stupidity that's destroying
people's reasonableness about success
Carolyn is with us in Allentown
Pennsylvania another one of our
millionaires what's your net worth
Carolyn hi Dave our net worth is about
1.25 cool what's it invested in our
house is worth about a half a million
dollars we have about 650 thousand in
our retirement we have forty five
thousand dollars in the college fund for
our daughter she eats
we have saved twenty five thousand
dollars for our next car how old are you
gosh we're 43 years old whoa young
millionaires good for you and what's
your average income been through your
long working lifetime um we probably
averaged about 80,000 what do you guys
do for a living what's your career
versus
yet my husband is an electrician and my
background is nursing I work for a
health education company now okay and
what are your degrees in so I I have my
undergraduate Bachelors of Science in
Nursing and then I have a master's
degree in health psychology and my
husband my husband didn't go to college
okay and your GPA
okay my undergrad was 2.9 and my
graduate was 3.8 cool and how much debt
have you guys used to a cause this net
worth to be here we we did buy our first
house when we were first married at 22
was 94 thousand dollars and we didn't
have any money I just about died I mean
I was throughout practically but we paid
that off in four years and that
motivated us to just stay out of debt so
you didn't have any other money did have
student loans uh we had my hat my
husband didn't go to college so I paid
my way through college and and so we
didn't really have we had like two
thousand dollars to pay off when we got
married and home but I might have a new
cars of you bought two but our last car
we paid for in cash and it was used and
that's the way we're going going forward
and did you inherit money we knew only I
wouldn't say we inherited money but I
worked really hard for a startup company
and when they went public I did get from
the stock I got a hundred thousand
dollars and that was about ten years ago
and we paid off our mortgage at that
time but that's not an inheritance now
that's just women now it was part of a
generation package now okay yeah that
was good and uh what part did giving
play yeah when we were first we got
married at 22 we didn't have any money
to give but we we gave a lot of our time
we volunteered a lot but as the years
have gone on it's really been real easy
to just give things away and then yeah
we give we give at least ten percent of
our of our money away now and it's fun
now because we we have certain causes
that are important to us and we can we
can give to them so that's a good thing
what's the most expensive jeans you buy
i buy all my clothes from a consignment
store i would say my average pair of
jeans is about four dollars and fifty
cents
that's ridiculous go get you some good
jeans
that's fabulous
yeah all right Carolyn you told
twice that a couple of these things like
buying the house and so forth scared you
so fear was kind of in the picture as
maybe maybe as a positive motivator I
don't know to tell the younger Carolyn
how she should do this and that she can
do this the younger version yeah I would
say try to get more sleep and stop
worrying so much because it will work
out and and to say thank you to your
husband Mike gosh she's such a hard
worker and what were the principles that
caused you guys to be millionaires I
think if you're talking to the younger
you do this do this don't do this don't
do that I would say work very very hard
when you're young because you're going
to get more tired we could get older and
you don't have the energy to do the
overtime but those early years pick up
as many hours as you can and and just
work and work and work and hang onto
your marriage it's roller coaster and
then eventually things will calm down
and you'll have more time for everything
and you won't need to be working so hard
and it works out oh yeah it works out so
were you steady in your investing or as
most of that been in the last few years
uh we're steady but we we definitely
have been able to invest more since
we've now we make more we don't pay
anybody any we no no does it occurred to
you that you're only 43 and so by the
time you're 63 you're probably going to
be worth 10 million I looked at those
calculators with disbelief
I don't know I'm scared about that I
will be fine I know we'll be fine it's a
comfort I can sleep well at night yeah
you're on your way there's no doubt if
you keep the same without the same work
ethic that I mean crazy amounts of work
but just if you just keep the same
disciplines and your financials out of
your life that's where this is headed in
20 years if you don't do much else if
you just keep control of what you're
doing and that's where the math will
take you so very very impressive thank
you so much for being a great American
success story
thank you I appreciate it that's very
very neat